oh i'll make you nervous  a guy asked me to call him daddy in bed  recently and it was father's day so i  was like okay i'll give it to you  i found the best way to discourage  something in bed that you're not into is  to try to ruin it for them so i gave it  at first  it was hard but i was like oh yeah does  daddy like that and by the end of it i  was just like  [Music]  he came right away  i am tired of you girls in your 20s  dating men my age who should be dating  me  according to all my 40 year old friends  there's like an epidemic of 20  somethings with old souls of course you  like the only thing old about a woman  that you can't see you never hear a guy  going she's 23 i know she's 23 nicki but  seriously she's got like the oldest  [ __ ]  i'm 37 all i do is talk about my vagina  on stage it's like enough  i'm just at this point in my career  where i'm ready to like close that  chapter and pivot like  [Music]  to my [ __ ] like you guys i have not  even begun  [Music]  you